[Música]
é você já se deram conta o quanto uma
orquestra formada somente de mulheres em
comum o quanto o ambiente musical ele é
predominantemente masculino
eu comecei a tocar bateria nos anos 80
naquela época já era dificílimo uma
mulher instrumentista ainda mais
baterista né ea minha convivência na
música no começo sempre foi com os homem
eu tive professores homens
eu tinha banda com homens eu ensaiava
com homens eu fazia show com homens
eu gravava com homens o técnico de som
era homem
o produtor musical era homem
o road que carrega dos instrumentos era
homem
o operador da mesa homem o dono da
gravadora homem o produtor da gravadora
homem produtor disse que era um homem
muito estranhamente se era homem
compositor homem arranjador o homem e
isso né a gente nota que o gênero da
música era predominantemente masculino
e ele ainda é eu sou professora de
bateria e percussão e sempre tive muitas
alunas mulheres e muitos alunos homens
eu não estava uma grande diferença assim
no que diz respeito à o comportamento de
gênero
os meus alunos homens eles vivenciavam a
música de uma maneira bem mais intensa
eles tinham bandas eles tocavam fazer um
show se escola em festa cíntia tros em
bairros
ao contrário
das minhas alunas mulheres que só
tocavam na sala de aula se apresentava
uma vez por ano
tocando uma única música é essa foto
aqui foi uma apresentação que a gente
fez de fim de ano em dezembro de 2014
então as minhas alunas tocar uma música
cada má fé o bar estava lotada disse ma
elas cada vez que saiam do pau eram
aplaudidíssimos por que tocaram muito
bem e saíram do palco um sorriso aqui e
daí eu fiquei pensando assim mas minha
gente de novo só daqui a um ano
só uma música é eu resolvi que essa
história teria que mudar justamente
nessa hora que eu reuni ela e falei que
eu ia criar um grupo um conjunto mor
questra seja lá o que fosse pra elas
colocarem a cara na rua pra elas
ocuparem um espaço que também era dela
naquela hora eu estava dando um empurrão
nela eu estava incentivando ela a tocar
mais aparecer mais a dominar o
instrumento
eu estava criando um projeto de
fortalecimento e acolhimento em março de
2015 dois meses depois nesse projeto
tomou forma e eu criei as batucadas
porque esta de bateria e percussão e
orquestra feminina né
eu coloquei um anúncio no face e essa
que foi a primeira o primeiro dia da
turma tinha oito mulheres
no segundo dia já tínhamos 20 mulheres
hoje nós somos 70 e temos também um
grupo vocal está completando um ano
é um animal é que elas não podem falar
nada nada ela tem que ficar assim ó a
minha intenção não foi simplesmente
criar um projeto de ensino e aprendizado
mas sim um espaço de múltiplo diálogos
um espaço de acolhimento um espaço de
fortalecimento um espaço onde a gente
pudesse mudar essa história ea gente
está mudando essa história
ontem um homem na batucada nas batucadas
é o vini silva
ele está comigo desde o começo ele me
ajuda nos arranjos na composição e
também é professor das batucadas na
verdade ele foi primeiro regente das
batucadas eu não região porque eu não
sabia
então eu também passei por um processo
de fortalecimento e de conhecimento da
regência a segunda pessoa que me ajuda
muito é minha filha tinha gripe atacar
de alinhar a júlia é a primeira mulher
baterista a entrar na faculdade de
música da ufrgs
as letras batuques em 2016 como aluna
hoje ela é uma baita de uma professora
da orquestra e também já está se
arriscando na regência as batatas em um
projeto que dá muito trabalho por isso
que eu preciso desses professores para
me ajudar nessa são três turmas com
níveis diferentes onde essas meninas
tocam instrumentos diferentes e nós
temos um repertório bem vasto
então a gente realmente tem que dominar
de início não é pouco bolinha gente a
gente se junta às vezes quase matar
harmonia das batucadas am e aí a gente
tem saído muito longos também muito
longas mais intensos e os arranjos são
mais difíceis porque eu quis unir com
harmonia o rock como foi que o jazz com
o samba o olodum e ijexá o regue com
outros ritmos
as batucadas é um projecto único
pioneiro e é transformador
nós somos mulheres de todas as idades
com pensamentos diferentes diferentes
maneiras de agir diferentes maneiras de
se pronunciar diferentes feminismos
diferentes cores de cabelo diferentes
roupas também e nós uniforme é de todas
as cores do nosso repertório abrange
vários ritmos
então a diversidade faz parte das
batucadas qualquer mulher que quer
aprender a tocar um instrumento pode
entrar
nós damos as mãos para trás ou para
todas e nos abraçamos
eu vou falar aqui de três depoimentos de
três basquete
uma delas é a glória que está aqui nossa
mascote hoje o tamanho dela
agora começo a tela comigo isso também a
glória falou que teve que trocar as
batucadas
ela se sente muito feliz né viu um mundo
melhor com mais solidariedade
aprendeu a tocar vários instrumentos
vários ritmos e que ela tem amizades dos
13 aos 60
a norma que daí a nã o hã
a norma como quem não tem nada foi
convidada pra assistir uma aula e ali
ficou
nela fala em solidariedade e amizade em
carinho comprometimento feminismo estudo
melhoria a rosa a cadeia rosich a minha
lua namibe desde o começo ela está na
foto ali do desde o primeiro dia a rosa
viu esse sonho crescer comigo e ela fala
que conviver com mulheres tão
maravilhosas trouxe muito mais pesam
para a vida dela
[Risadas]
então é isso
á a música é a nossa fala a percussão
a batucada é a nossa voz
nós estamos super felizes de estar aqui
nós adoramos estar aqui nós gostamos de
ter as orquestras e para nós não é nada
incomum que isso aconteça
guria eu amo você de coração
e eu só queria acabar com uma coisinha
como táctica tatum
vocês vão fazer o tumulto um bem forte
eu quero tudo muito bem forte
só patetas guri a sobra é então se eu
vou fazer troca de cantar você não fazer
tudo tá faltar garra de cada vôo ou a
muito bom
obrigada
valeu agora a gente vai tocar múrias
forte firme e forte é pachuca danske das
que tampa 23
[Música]
ai ai ai ai
a galera
[Música]
ae
[Aplausos]